[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN: Hello and
welcome to Game On!
Episode 4.
I am Todd Kerpelman.
I'm a developer advocate
here on Play Games.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Hello.
My name is Hakuro Matsuda,
Android developer advocate for
Game Technology.
TODD KERPELMAN: And today we're
going to be talking
about OpenGL ES 3.0.
Before we get into that,
let's jump into
some news and updates.
Not a whole lot, this time, in
terms of news and updates.
Except that we've got more
info on Cloud Save.
This guy, Tom Fitzgerald, who
happens to be a googler,
emailed me earlier today and
said, hey, I saw your show--
so we have at least
one viewer.
Thanks, Tom.
--about Cloud Save.
And I went and added it into
my own HTML5 game.
And he put up a YouTube video
where he talks about the
process, shows you his code.
It's pretty quick.
It's all of about three
and a half minutes.
But if you're at all interested
in doing more with
Cloud Save, particularly in a
web-based game, I encourage
you to check it out.
And I suppose this is something
that's important to
point out, is Cloud Save, it's
not just for mobile games.
It's also very useful in
a browser-based game.
Local storage is very
cool for HTML5.
But it does have the
disadvantage that you,
basically, can't keep your
storage between browsers or,
obviously, across different
computers.
That's why it's called
local storage.
And so, if you have to deal with
a player that is either
playing on different browsers,
or on different computers, or
on a tablet and a computer,
again, look into Cloud Save.
And you can look into what this
guy, Tom, has done in his
YouTube video.
So with that, let's get into
the main subject of today's
talk and that is OpenGL ES 3.
Hakuro, you're an expert.
So I'll let you take it away.
HAKURO MATSUDA: OK.
So for today, I'd like to
introduce you to new API
Android 4.3, OpenGL ES 3.
OpenGL ES 3 is a superset of
existing OpenGL ES 2, so that
you can use your existing game
code for OpenGL ES 2 without
any changes.
You can adopt some of the
advanced features of OpenGL 3
and get benefit of
them quite easy.
In ES 3, it supports multiple
new features, which can be
categorized into three areas--
performance, quality,
and flexibility.
For performance, ES 3 supports
several advanced features such
as the transform feedback,
geometric instancing,
occlusion query, and multiple
rendering target.
The transform feedback is quite
useful feature to the
math in GPU side rather
than CPU side.
You can update your vertex
[? performed ?] project
entries directory based on the
math done at GPU without
involving any CPU.
This is good for using the
particle engine, or such as
the skinning done in GPU
with multiple rendering
[? targets. ?]
Also, geometry instancing is
a feature that can render
multiple instances of geometry
with just one API call with
different parameters.
The feature is good for both
CPU and GPU performance,
because you don't have to
call API multiple times.
And also, GPU has hardware
support to handle the same
efficiently.
For games that render the same
object multiple times, you
should use that feature.
Other features, such as MRT,
which can render to multiple
renderable files at the same
time, and occlusion query,
which can check GPU if geometry
is visible or not.
GL also great to reduce both CPU
and GPU load dramatically.
Let's talk about quality side.
In ES 3 it supports ETC 2
as the standard texture
compression format.
ETC 2 supports the alpha channel
and produces better
quality for bit part channel,
which is quite smaller than
regular texture format.
It replaces ETC 1 and various
other GPU dependent
formats, like DXT.
So that you can finally use one
single texture compression
format in your games
with GL ES 3.
Also, as an optional feature,
you can have ASTC, Adaptive
Scalable Texture Compression
format, texture format, that
is much more advanced and better
quality texture format.
ASTC is supported in some
GPUs such as Mali GPU.
ES 3 also supports floating
point textures so that you can
do real High Dynamic Range
rendering video games,
not the fake HDR.
For flexibility side, it
supports features like
non-power-of-two textures so
that you can have [INAUDIBLE]
dimension of the textures,
not limited to the
power-of-two size.
And it's supports more than
the target format and the
texture format, as well.
Also, you can attach depth
for the texture.
In ES 3, shading language is
also updated to GLSL ES 3.0,
which support integer and has
new language features.
So in general, ES 3 supports
comparable features of the
desktop version of OpenGL 3.1 or
DirectX 10, except support
of geometry shader which can
produce more triangles after
vertex shader stage.
So that with GL ES 3 you can
port your games quite easy to
mobile port form.
In performance wise, mobile GPUs
with GL ES 3 support has
comparable performance range of
low or middle range desktop
GPU, which is quite surprising
for me, because mobile GPU
works on 1/10 low-energy
usage.
Currently, SDK 18 and NDK R9,
both supports GL ES 3.
And all of Nexus 4, 7,
10 supports GL ES 3.
Please try new feature set of
GL ES 3, and enjoy them.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well, cool.
That all sounds very
exciting to--
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: --somebody
that likes good
graphics in my games.
I wanted to ask about when you
talked about some of the
performance improvement.
So geometry instancing,
I think I understand.
Like if I had 15 cars in my game
that all were essentially
the same, I would essentially
only define one car model--
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: --and kind
of save on a whole lot of
geometry passing by saying, just
reuse this car model in
multiple places.
HAKURO MATSUDA: In GL ES 2,
you had to code the API 15
times in this example, but with
GL ES 3, you can render
15 cars at one single
API code.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's cool.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yeah, in
Android, basically, API code,
it's not quite cheap, so that
it's a great performance
[INAUDIBLE].
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
Now, could I have different
textures or different colors
on top of these cars and
still take advantage?
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yes, exactly.
So you can have different
parameters, like transform
texture UVs, and any other
parameter can be different by
model instance.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
So I feel like at one point
there was a lot of games that
featured crowd scenes where,
all of a sudden, they were
drawing a lot of people.
They're basically taking
advantage of this technique,
and putting different skins on
the same model so that you get
the impression of
a lot of people.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
Well, that's very clever.
I still don't quite understand
what transform feedbacks are.
Is that something you can
explain further, or is that
really just like--
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yes.
So in general, in ES 2, the
transform or GPU method is
just one way.
So CPU issues a render
command.
And the GPU does some
work and render it.
That was it.
But in OpenGL ES 3, you
can [? feed back ?]
the output math of the GPU into
the buffer again, so that
you can update the geometry
skin or you can update
particle position inside GPU and
right back to the buffer.
So that in each way you
can do the math
completely in the GPU side.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, OK.
That's starting to make
more sense to me.
So would that work if I had to,
say, perform the same kind
of transform in-scale
to multiple objects?
Could I take advantage of
that feature there?
HAKURO MATSUDA: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
And MRT, Multiple Render
Targets, is that like the
feature where I can--
sometimes in the background
you might see a TV that's
showing what's going
on in my game?
Is that that technique or--
HAKURO MATSUDA: Oh, well, it's
mainly for the multiple paths.
In GL ES 2, to do the multiple
path rendering effect, you had
to render the normal at
this path, and the
color at this path.
And that's the final gathering
path you need to fetch these,
then the result, that's the
final gathering path.
But in the MRT you can output
two different values in two
different target.
So that you don't have
to draw same thing
twice, but just once.
And at the final gathering
path before the rendering
path, you can get two result
at the same time.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
So what techniques would you
see making use of MRT?
HAKURO MATSUDA: Well, we said,
before the rendering
technique--
several parameters of objects
into several buffers, and to
get that final path, you can
get a great benefit through
MRT in terms of the
performance.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yes.
Well, let's see.
I think we have--
let's move on to a demo.
We've got a cool demo that was
put together by the good folks
at Silicon Studio.
I guess this is--
I don't know if it has a name,
except maybe "Rings and
Jewels," that we showed off at
the Nexus 7 watch event, just
last month, that makes use of
some fairly cool ES 3.0
techniques.
Let's bring this up.
This is recorded on a new Nexus
7 device that I think
Dan said I could keep after
this session is done.
He's laughing, which
I think means yes.
So we've got these very
cool shiny rings.
And I can click this Add button,
and add in a few
jewels, and they fall down
and knock over the rings.
And it looks very cool.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yeah, physics
simulation in the CPU side.
It's really cool physics.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
it's nice physics.
So what are we seeing here
that's being done by GL ES 3?
HAKURO MATSUDA: Well, in GL ES
3 mode, they are using a
floating texture so that
everything is rendered in the
high dynamic range.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK I've noticed
there, there's a
switch here.
I can switch ES 3 on and off.
And I notice, when I turn
it off, there's a
few things that happen.
One, you don't get the
nice shine on the
rings like you do before.
You get a little bit of lens
flare off the ring
reflections, and
that goes away.
I've also noticed the table
texture looks much blurrier.
What's happening there?
HAKURO MATSUDA: Right, so in
the fake HDR mode, which is
with OpenGL ES 2, everything had
to be in the range of the
0 to 255, which is
1 byte range.
But in OpenGL ES 3, it can have
the float dynamic range
so that it can show more
details on everything.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
And so that's why, when I
turn on the GL ES 3.0--
we need a cooler code
name for that--
that's why the table suddenly
looks so much more detailed,
is we're able to suddenly
spend more--
basically more data
per pixel on--
HAKURO MATSUDA: Right,
precisely.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
I notice something also seems to
be happening with the gems.
I'm not quite sure.
Is it somehow doing different
type of refraction?
HAKURO MATSUDA: Mm-hmm.
TODD KERPELMAN: When I switch
on and off ES 3.0, I notice
that there's something that I
can't quite articulate with
the gems where they look
much better with it on.
And I don't quite know what's
going on there.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Basically, it's
also thanks to the high
dynamic range.
So the edge of the jewels can
be sharper and the friction
can be clearer in the GL ES 3.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
All right, well cool.
I could play with this for a
long time, but I won't because
we have other stuff
to do in our show.
But excellent.
So let's see-- other Q&A. So
in terms of what devices
support OpenGL ES 3, you had
mentioned the Nexus 4,
the new Nexus 7.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Nexus 7, yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: And
the Nexus 10.
Are there other devices
out there?
How would I know if a
device supports--
HAKURO MATSUDA: Well, in
general, as of today, GPU from
Qualcomm, like Adreno
320 and 330 should
support the GL ES 3.
Also, GPU from ARM, Mali-T600,
should support the GL ES 3.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK, well
maybe that brings us
to our third question.
So if I'm a developer, and maybe
I want to add in some of
this OpenGL ES 3 techniques
to my game.
But at the same time, you
actually want to support a
large range of devices, what
do you do with your code to
make sure that you can still--
basically, to make sure that I
can kind of have an engine
that looks really nice on the
machines that support it, but
doesn't crash or something
on the [INAUDIBLE].
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yeah, that's
a great question.
TODD KERPELMAN: Thanks.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yeah, so as of
today, almost all of the
Android devices, like 99% of
the devices, supports the
OpenGL ES 2.
But just a fraction of a percent
supports the GL ES 3.
TODD KERPELMAN: That number will
probably grow now that
we've announced it.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yeah, in
the future inevitably.
That's my hope.
But as of today, you need to
have the two code per line for
GL ES 3, and another
one for GL ES 2.
Also, you can check the
existence of some OpenGL GPU
extension, so that you can,
even with GL ES 2, you can
still utilize some of the
advanced feature set available
for GL ES 3.
TODD KERPELMAN: So I might,
for instance--
some hardware manufacturer
might have a chipset that
officially supports GS 2, but
might support one or two
features from the OpenGL ES 3?
HAKURO MATSUDA: Right.
TODD KERPELMAN: And so that's
something that a developer
could check on a feature
by feature basis?
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yeah, exactly.
So it sounds very complicated.
But it's kind of like
PC gaming models.
So in the PC, you need to check
all of the features
existing to utilize most out of
GPU hardware, so that you
need to do the same thing
in Android device.
TODD KERPELMAN: So yeah, it's
really not much different than
what a lot of PC developers
are already doing today.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Right.
TODD KERPELMAN: And maybe that
brings us to our second
question, which is, I might
decide, as a game developer,
this sounds like
a lot of work.
Maybe I'll find an engine
to do this for me.
Are there other engines
out there that
support this already?
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yes, so many
game engines, like Unity and
the Unreal engine already
support GL ES 3 so that, for
me, GL ES 3 is really
easy to use.
But for somebody, it might not,
so that you can still use
a game engine to support the GL
ES 3 advanced feature set.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
And I guess, actually,
that might bring up--
good segue.
We do have one other demo, which
is the Unity engine.
And I suppose maybe some of
this really isn't so much
showing OpenGL ES 3 features so
much as kind of showing how
nice things look
on the Nexus 7.
But it sounds like they are
probably doing a fair amount
of OpenGL ES 3 performance
improvements.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yeah, exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: We're
going to run this.
This is called "The Chase." And
I noticed they are showing
a fair number of features going
on here in terms of
atmospheric scattering, a four
kilometer draw distance.
I think they talk about sub--
yeah.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yes.
They are using a really
high-polygon model.
And the entire scene, it's
rendering more than 250,000
polygons in that scene, which
is an incredibly high number
in terms of mobile gaming.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
I mean, this looks
like a console game.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yeah, exactly.
And also, they are using some
advanced features [INAUDIBLE]
OpenGL ES 3 for performance
improvement, mainly.
So that with ES 2 devices,
the demo still works.
But with ES 3, it can utilize
features like occlusion
coloring to check if a sign
is visible in the scene.
And also, it's using geometry
instanced rendering so that it
can benefit the performance of
the GL ES 3 feature set.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
well that's very cool.
My biggest complaint with this
demo is, I can't figure out
who the good guy and
who the bad guy is.
They both sort of look
kind of sinister.
They are both shooting in
amongst all the civilian
traffic, which really
isn't all that safe.
Maybe neither one is actually
the good guy.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Maybe.
TODD KERPELMAN: But I suppose
that's a little off topic.
So awesome.
This looks great.
I can't wait to try out more
games on this device that Dan
is letting me take home.
So thanks again, Dan.
And we'll bring up our final
slide, which is, if you want
more information about OpenGL
ES 3, this is basically our
OpenGL page on
developer.android.com.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yes, also we are
releasing some more sample
code for [INAUDIBLE]
for OpenGL ES 3.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
would be fantastic.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: Awesome.
All right, well thank you very
much for joining us.
HAKURO MATSUDA: Thank you.
TODD KERPELMAN: Thank you out
there for joining us.
And we will see you in a couple
weeks with our next
"Game On" session--
if we don't get cancelled.